[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy buenas tardes
qué gusto y antes de empezar a compartir
mi experiencia mi admiración respeto ha
sacado en los conferencistas que estamos
aquí en 'the lex las experiencias son
increíbles y tus manos ya está concierto
personal con álex simplemente es
increíble
y para mí es un honor poder compartir
con ustedes lo que ha sido una
experiencia de vida lo que significa
para mí el deporte y que al final del
día he hecho una filosofía de vida de
ello de este gran maestro de vida que es
el deporte me enseña muchísimas cosas y
en estas tres horas y media que voy a
platicar con ustedes no es cierto en
estos minutos que me permiten trataré de
resumir lo que significa esta
herramienta mis papás no me llevaron al
deporte para ser medallista olímpico mis
papás me llevaron al deporte por salud
porque querían un niño sanos
nunca se pensaron que mis hermanos
salían muy buenos nadadores y fuera
necesitas centroamericanos o yo
medallista olímpico mi mamá es asmática
que le preocupaba que sus hijos fueran
sanos yo soy hijo del instituto mexicano
del seguro social empecé a la unidad por
tema y ahí aprendí todo pero la verdad
es que era un niño que no le interesaba
el deporte que le interesaba divertirse
pero me topé con un deporte que
simplemente fue amor a primera vista
los clavados llegues al ver que y de
repente bien niños brincar dar vueltas
camas elásticas plataforma de cinco
metros pero ver que un cuate se suba a
la plataforma de diez pararse de manos y
de parada manos da una vuelta y caí al
agua
yo me volteé con mi entrado elije yo
quiero hacer es sea lo que sea mi primer
entrenador fue también clavadista
olímpico en moscú 80 salvador sobrino y
él me enseñó que además y lo voy a decir
como presumido además méxico en este
deporte somos potencia mundial no de oye
ojo si les digo rommel pacheco paula
espinoza iván garcía y germán sánchez
todos se lo saben pero les tendría que
decir
antonio mariscal joaquín capilla álvaro
gaxiola los niños ribera carlos girón
jesús mena mari josé alcalá estás
hablando desde 1940 hasta el 2019 y
méxico siempre tiene mexicanos dentro de
los ocho mejores
tiene un campeonato mundial foso
olímpico si dicen méxico es una
posibilidad de medalla mi entrenador
salvador sobrino hoy en día es
entrenador nacional en australia y tiene
tres medallas olímpicas con el equipo
australiano y él me enseñó que había un
grupo selecto que se llamaban
medallistas olímpicos y que las
historias eran de seres humanos así
empezó mi carrera así empezó mi sueño
por querer pertenecer a ese grupo y
empezaron la verdad muy buenos
resultados desde los 15 años yo ya
estaba en un selectivo juegos olímpicos
para barcelona 92 fue mi primer ciclo y
este maestro de vida te premia cuando
demi pero te da unos jalones de oreja
también cuando lo necesitas para
barcelona-92 yo tenía 19 años
simplemente superman se quedaba corto
para llegar a juegos olímpicos fractura
de la mano izquierda fractura de estrés
pasar rehabilitación cirugía llegar a
juegos olímpicos fue complicado pero fue
una de las mejores experiencias tuve que
empezar a hacer algo que a veces no
hacemos en el día a día me tuve que
preguntar cuáles son las cualidades y
defectos de fernando conocerlo al 100%
saben por qué porque no podía entrenar
de la misma manera y además la lección
más fuerte fue ojo
estás disfrutando lo que haces lo
disfrutas como si fuera la única vez
como si fuera la primera vez que te
paradas en un albergue en juegos
olímpicos hubiera 10.000 15.000
espectadores y más de 20 cámaras que
creen paso barcelona que de 19º no pase
a finales pero lo que más me dolió fue
no disfrutar mis buenos juegos olímpicos
y cada ciclo olímpico hay que renovarse
porque no empiezas con 20 puntos porque
fuiste ajos olímpicos a ver no el
siguiente selectivo empiezas de cero
puntos y te tienes que renovar el
siguiente ciclo fue para atlanta 96 mi
historia es que hasta los terceros
juegos olímpicos ganen una talla
posiblemente en ese grupo de los 20 30
niños de 9 años que empezaron conmigo
habían niños con mejores cualidades
físicas pero yo tenía dos cualidades muy
buenas perseverancia y me encantaba
competir para atlanta 96 gane todo lo
que había que ganar centroamericanos
panamericanos copas del mundo campeonato
mundial fue los niveles universitarios
premio nacional del deporte pres estado
de mexico y ya no más me faltaba vender
moles los mismos
y lo hubiera hecho bien
llegué atlanta-96 séptimo y octavo que
pasó
simplemente me tenía que hacer una
pregunta y haber habría que hacerla
fríamente fernando puede o no puede ser
medallista y te tienes que contestar y
te tienes que contestar objetivamente y
fríamente decir sí sí y ponerte a
trabajar yo creo que en esta vida hay
dos tipos de personas los soñadores y
los que se ponen a trabajar por sus
sueños
y clavados me enseñó que las
competencias no se ganan y la
competencia no das tu extra el día de la
competencia sales inspirado el de la
competencia das tu extra cuando tiras
250 clavados diarios y el entrador te
dice uno más
sales inspirado cuando las cosas en esos
250 clavados no te salen y el entrenador
te dice otra vez
y sabes disfrutar el estrés cuando te
preparas también que no importa que la
competencia sea la más cerrada estás en
el lugar ideal
esa fue mi lección de atlanta 96 cuál
fue la diferencia para sydney
madurez y que todo lo que aprendí
llegaba en ese momento aprendí que la
disciplina no era no como más no te des
vélez no la disciplina es hacer bien
todo lo que tienes que hacer todos los
días las 250 veces que el liderazgo es
que estás con toda la gente que es un
líder en tu equipo que respeta el
trabajo de los demás y que ese equipo se
podría poner el reto más grande ganarle
a los mejores en la mejor competencia
tuve la fortuna de que los mejores
clavadistas posiblemente icónicamente
durante muchos años en mi deporte
estaban en mi generación dmitry sautin
de rusia y johnny de china posiblemente
los más ganadores de medallas olímpicas
por encima de greg louganis porque a
greg lugares la mayoría de la gente lo
publica pero ellos tienen más números de
medallas y yo le quería ganar a ellos en
la mejor competencia
me preparé y se mi estrategia
pero el déjenme decirles algo saben cuál
fue la diferencia que hice lo que yo
sabía hacer yo sabía que competía muy
bien y que manejaba el estrés pero
además sabía que podía competir les a
cada uno de ellos de frente posiblemente
una de las finales de tres metros más
cerradas
250 clavados significan 70.000 clavados
al año les recuerdo que eran mis
terceros juegos olímpicos y cada ciclo
olímpico tiene 4 años
valen la pena esos doscientos cincuenta
y setenta mil esos dos 180 mil sí
por una hora 10 que dura la final 12
clavadistas 6 clavados pero todo se
resume en la última ronda
esa última ronda en la que todo el mundo
sueña ganando la medalla yo salía de un
pasillo llego con mi entrenador jorge
rueda y le digo jorge boido cima al
frente con dos giros me dice que vas a
hacer
no alimente nada le dije lo que hacían
las 250 veces todos los días
estirar los brazos brincar mucho y ver
bien el agua jorge jala la silla se
siente me dice amigo yo voy a disfrutar
tu competencia dice porque venimos a
ganar
sal y mis vueltas y giros entra al agua
sal yo ya había hecho mi chamba
les voy a confesar algo de la alberca
donde estaba mi entrenador eso si no lo
había entrenado y empiezo a caminar como
potrillo recién nacido llegó y le digo
george ya somos medallistas y me dice sí
pero el ruso no puede con el estrés sale
dmitry sautin 2 y me hablan de es con
dos giros y medio y cai corto
y yo ya había hecho 700 8.42 y dmitry
sautin hacía 700 3.20 le ganábamos al 1
del mundo en la mejor competencia pero
nos faltaba
jon y sale 3 y más adentro cae salimos y
vemos en esa pantalla gigante el
resultado final son ni de china 700 8.72
fernando platas de mexico 700 8.42 y
dmitry sautin de rusias de 700 3.20 si
las en la final más cerrada si hay un
momento importantísimo y no sucede nada
malo
lo que sucede es que te das cuenta que
gracias a tus amigos gracias a la
competencia
pudiste mejorar año con año y estás con
los mejores del mundo yo conocí a dmitry
sautin a los 15 años
jason y a los 14 y competimos durante 12
años juntos la competencia te sirve y la
crítica tienes a una persona todos los
días como este entrenador diciéndote que
está mal pero el tema es que lo puedes
mejorar mi deporte me dio la oportunidad
de llegar a otros juegos olímpicos desde
portar la bandera de tu país en dos
juegos olímpicos pero también te deja
que tienes que tener herramientas para
el siguiente paso
retiro posiblemente una de las lecciones
más difíciles que puede tener un atleta
dejar de hacer lo que has hecho toda tu
vida toda tu vida es el último clavado y
literalmente vas a colgar el traje de
baño
saben que sucedió para atenas-2004
lo mismo que sucedió en sydney la
diferencia es que el objetivo era más
grande y se llamaba satisfacción
personal estar contento con lo que has
hecho toda tu vida tirarte su último
clavado y salir sonriendo y decir sí
hice una carrera y le hice como yo
quería
y deporte me enseñó que la competencia
más importante que tenemos es con uno
mismo
hablaban de los miedos se han hablado de
la persistencia enclavados el miedo es
bien objetivo estás en la orilla de la
plataforma de 10 metros y te quieres
tirar y no te puedes mover se llama
miedo y el único que se puede dar la
oportunidad de hacerlo eres tú
tú eres el único que puede dar ese paso
yo no le eche ni más porras al chino ni
le metió un pie el ruso yo hice lo que
yo sabía hacer y sin lugar a duda algo
que me ha definido como persona son los
valores casualmente el movimiento
olímpico y el deporte te enseña
claramente qué significa respeto por el
contrincante las reglas del compañero el
juego limpio no son herramientas nada
más por decir de verdad son valores que
te marcan en tu vida todo lo que les
acabo de contar sucedió en menos de 24
años y se lo estoy contando casi en diez
minutos créanme
si pasa el tiempo volando yo nunca pensé
es decir que hace 19 años había ganado
mi medalla
hoy tengo 45 y hoy evalúo mis proyectos
si me tiemblan las piernas y se me sale
el corazón como en ese último clavado
desciende porque es lo que me apasiona
sin lugar a duda y tengo dos grandes
proyectos en esta vida
el honor de formar una familia con una
excelente mujer mi esposa daniela y
tengo la gran responsabilidad de tratar
de ser el mejor padre de dos chamacos de
feria de mateo y me emociona díaz díaz
serlo nosotros le damos la definición a
las cosas nosotros le damos el sentido a
las cosas el éxito si es un estilo de
vida es como todos los días nos
levantamos y hacemos cada una de
nuestras acciones no queramos
transformar más allá de nuestra casa
empecemos por nuestra casa empecemos por
nuestros amigos yo les acabo de contar
lo que en realidad le da el sentido a mi
medalla la medalla es un material es más
esta es la medalla olímpica y créanme
créanme
que si yo no les hubiera contado todo lo
que hoy platicamos no tendría ningún
valor esto es más podríamos ir al monte
de piedad'
y nos daría mucho coraje en lo que nos
dieran porque todo lo que les platiqué
es lo que le da sentido a esto y 10 es
la gran enseñanza que me hizo el deporte
saber que tú puedes mejorar saber que tu
día a día puedes buscar la mejor versión
de ti siempre y cuando te apasione
siempre y cuando de verdad estés al 100%
con tu proyecto déjenme decirles una
última enseñanza cuando te paras de
manos en esa plataforma de 10 metros lo
único que ves en tus manos es la orilla
de la plataforma tus dedos a 10 metros
de distancia el agua y sientes las
puntitas de tus pies tambaleando
en ese momento entiendes perfectamente
que el mejor lugar donde puedes tener
los pies
es en el piso y se llama humildad se
llama que cuando ustedes logren grandes
cosas
recuerden quiénes son de dónde vienen y
el trabajo que les ha costado llegar a
hoy
a dónde están yo empezaba reconociendo a
todos los conferencistas de hoy porque
cada uno de ellos además de su gran
historia nos han demostrado que son
grandes seres humanos porque porque
saben perfectamente quiénes son hagan un
ejercicio cada uno de ustedes lleguen a
su casa vean se vea frente al espejo y
cuenten su historia hasta el día de hoy
y se van a dar cuenta que han dejado de
admirar una persona todos los días que
ha logrado grandes cosas que son
ustedes el día que terminemos de
asombrarnos de las cosas y dejar de
aprender de las demás personas perdemos
dinámica perdemos esas ganas de seguir
avanzando déjenme contarles un día en un
entrenamiento salían los clavados se
estaba haciendo un clavado nuevo y no lo
podía no lo podía llegar caía corto y me
pegaba en las piernas y me pegaban las
piernas
salgo todo enojado tenía muy mal
carácter tren ando salgo todo enojado
aventando las cosas
el chino el chino era la persona que
limpiaba la alberca
quizás me acerque el chino y me dice oye
fer no estás llegando el clavado
y luego chino ahora en ese entrenador
dice no
como que no eres tú voy
lo que me quieres decir dice siempre
estás entrenando disfrutándolo sonriendo
y haciendo muy buen equipo me sé hoy no
eres tú
una persona que me voy a entrenar 12
años claro que sabía algo estaba
sucediendo mal al siguiente día llegué y
lo primero que pensé es no tengo que
cambiar como soy porque sé quién soy y
sé a dónde quiero llegar el chino el que
limpiaban la alberca
no pierdan la oportunidad de seguir
aprendiendo de cada una de las personas
seguramente en el camino nos vamos a
encontrar espero que nos reconozcamos
porque seguramente yo voy a estar más
canoso pero que nos veamos y me cuenten
cómo va su medalla olímpica cómo va su
gran proyecto porque en cada uno de
nosotros seguramente tenemos una mejor
versión bendiciones que dios bendiga
muchas gracias